Spring is a network operating system and the clients
and the servers can be on the same machine, can
be on different nodes on a local area network and
in the Spring system, what they wanted to do was
this idea of extensibility. They wanted to carry it to
saying the client and the server should be impervious to
where they are in the entire network. So the interaction
should be freed. Or in other words, the client server
interaction should be freed from the physical location of
the clients and the servers. So for instance, in
this picture, the clients and the servers are on
the same machine. We've decided to replicate the servers
in order to increase the availability, and now we
have several copies of the servers and the clients
are dynamically loaded to different servers for load distribution.
And for those of you who are familiar with,
you know, how services like Google work today,
this is exactly what happens in services that we
use on an everyday basis when we access Google.
Our client requests are being routed to different servers
and this is the same sort of thing
that is happening in the Spring system that once
you replicate the server, you want the client request
to be routed to different servers depending on the
physical proximity of the client to the servers, as
well as the load that is currently being handled by
one server versus another. Another variation of the same
theme is where the server is not replicated, but the
server is cached, for instance if it is a
web server. Then there could be a proxy for the
web, web server that is cached, and in that case
the client request need not go to the origin web
server, but it can go to the cached
copies that are available. And so here again this
decision of routing a client request to a
particular cached copy of the server is dynamically taken.
Not all of this sounds like magic in
terms of how this client server relationship is being
dynamically orchestrated, whether are in the same machine, or
whether we dynamically decide to replicate the servers and
decide to route the request to different servers, or we want to
cache the servers and route the client request to different cache copies.
All of these are dynamic decision that are taken. And how is
this done? Well that's the part that we're going to see next.